hello everyone Welcome to our talk uh
today we're going to be talking about
turning your data AI governs into full
web apps using only Python and very
quickly uh quick notes about this talk
as you said I'm Alex this is floron we
both work in customer success at tyi I'm
going to do a quick presentations with a
a few slides and then floron is going to
do some live demos and we should be
good all right so let's
start the problem
uh in 2019 Gardner released a study
where they predicted that only 20% of uh
data analytics projects would actually
deliver results that's extremely low
while companies are spending $270
billion do on business intelligence
that's the problem we wanted to tackle
in 2020 Vic released another study where
they wanted to look at the causes of why
data projects were always failing so
their first idea was well only 23% of
companies find the right Talent so the
issue when you're working in data or ml
is that you don't need to be only good
at ml at math or statistics you'll still
need devop skills because you're going
to be deploying your product serving it
monitoring performances and you also
need front-end skills because if your
dashboard is ugly no one's going to use
it so the first issue is
scill and afterwards we've got almost
90% of data applications take too long
and are too costly to develop and deploy
so generally in machine learning and
production the issue is that everyone
thinks that prototyping is the biggest
part doing your model is the biggest
part in reality it's only 30% of your
work generally you'll have to deploy
you'll have to monitor performance
retrain do support that's going to be
the big part and that's often not
anticipated so that's why projects
fail all right so we've talked about
problems and the fre causes now where
does tyi comes in um so typi uh we're an
open source python Library you can pip
install us and here's an example where I
code a simple uh web app where I just
have a chart that's Dynamic interactive
so here I just uh import II import
paness I load a CSV data set that's how
we write uh Pages we use the markdown
syntax so here I have a title here I
have visual elements so here I have a
slider that's connected to my number of
points python integer I do run and with
those simple steps in only 17 lines of
code I have my locally hosted web app uh
with a slider that's moving a chart
around so why is this useful well in
terms of talent I just coded a web app
using only python I didn't need to
Outsource any uh front end scills like
react in terms of time I just locally
hosted a web app in 17 lines of code if
you try to do the same in react it's not
the same thing and in terms of cost well
if you have a data analy data analytics
team uh it reduces your text tag to only
python you don't need to learn any other
new
languages we also deal with backend so
part of our product is called typei core
uh we have a vs code extension that
allows you to manage data PL frames in a
graph-based editor so here that's a
simple machine learning prediction
pipeline uh the blue nodes like this one
are data nodes where you can either
connect to an external database whether
it's SQL S3 or anything else or it can
be just a CSV file or a python
variable the orange nodes are task nodes
these are basically python functions
that convert data into new
data and with this you can do well data
plants why is this useful well well in
terms of talent this is a visual low
code approach to managing data so it
requires Le experience in data
Engineering in terms of time and cost we
do a few things to save so for example
typi will always save your pipelines
results with versioning it's easy to
compare runs of different scenarios uh
we don't rerun what does not need to be
so we have a caching system for example
this task clean data the first time you
run this pipeline we'll run it to clean
the DAT data sets the second time will
run and every other time after this we
will never clean the data because we
have stored clean data sets and we'll
always do this
one another thing is it's really easy to
plug into these blue nodes any common
data sources that you have in your wer V
whether it's azour AWS or Google
Cloud so I've talked about the problem
we wanted to tackle the free causes and
how does tyi attack them now
results so we worked with Anar which is
a big French retailer and one of their
teams wanted to create a cash flow
management app they didn't have the
skills in house to do this so their
first option was well Outsourcing you
hire four people outside your company it
takes 8 months 600k that's what they did
and it was fine they had their cash flow
management app but the issue is well you
spent 8 months and you spent 600k so we
went to their team and we told them well
you you have a data anonyx team that
knows already python so let us help you
create the same app that respects the
same requirements with your own people
so we took two of their people we
trained them a bit with tyi they worked
with python and with only 60k of budget
and two months of work they had an app
that respected the same requirements so
that's really the main leverage of typi
it successful deployments at reduced
cost and time I'll hand over
uh the mic to flor ja yes so I'm going
to do a demo of tyi so first of all I'm
going to show you an application that we
have built with tyi a simple dashboard
really just single page that will show
you how it looks like so it is just a
dashboard about uh Stoke price analysis
where you can change the date for your
eal data you can change the Ticker on
which you want to predict on change
maybe the number of heres you want to
predict and then you have buttons and
it's going to create you some forecast
with your hisorical data so a lot of
different uh visual elements different
charts tables this kind of things are
very interactive and it's not to like
show like a complete application here
it's that this application is done with
just 120 lines of code so really the
goal of typ is really to be easy to
create an application it's not just for
Pilots it's also for like polition ready
applications so well I'm going to show
you how you can create your first
application with
tyi so I'm going to go here and uh this
so here I will create really a simple
the simplest application with tyi that
can do which is just basically um you
have pimp install tyi so now you can use
it you can import it and then you can
create your first web page um I have
done here importing the
G and then I have created my M syntax so
this represents my page if you know Mark
down well this will tell you that the
hashtag is the title here and Theo will
be NX this like really simple way to
style your text uh with this way of
creating a page and you put this page
into the gree and run it and this will
give you basically just this so of
course here it's really really simple
you have just p in St typy I have
created this well I have imported this G
element put this string that represents
my page into the G and run it and I have
my mark down type by demo type by demo
as title and demo in
italic so I want to do something a bit
like better I want maybe to connect to
my um python environment I want to show
value that value is equal to uh to 10 so
I'm just going to create value and um
like to be able to connect to your
python environment you will need to use
typey visual elements we have always the
same syntax in Van pipe
then you will put your bound variable so
the one that you want to display to
modify to change whatever here I want to
just show value so 10 so I'm going to
put that here and here you put the name
of your visual element that you want to
have so you have a lot of different
visual elements here I just want a text
to show uh my value so basically
this I'm going to run my app and you
will see value 10 great but of course I
cannot change anything uh it's fixed
it's just a text but I have been able to
connect to my python environment just
like this using this typey visual
element here that you see if I want to
modify this value I can create another
visual element for example I can create
a slider so I'm going to take this same
here change my name I want to have a
slider but it's connecting to the same
value so the same band variable but I
want to um to to modify
so I save
it and then you will see that I have
value 10 and I have a slider when I'm
going to change my slider is also going
to change my value so with typy it's
really easy to have this kind of uh
synchronization between your different
variables you don't have to write
anything no C bags uh your app will be
like refreshed instantly with this kind
of bound variables that we have here
like in this internal logic that we have
in
tyy um but normally in dashboards like
in data applications you want to show
some charts some tables so I'm just
going to create some data for you uh
that will be able to um to then
show so here it is like a really uh
simple data that I am just importing is
I'm going to create a list of cosign
that would care of the time obviously
can also be like a CSV an Excel file can
be a pandas numai whatever it is a list
and I'm just putting it to my data and
now I want to show this data in my app
so what I'm going to do same thing type
I element I want to show my data as a
chart and maybe I also want to show it
as a
table and so like this I can just
refresh and we will see uh this uh chart
this go sign that is taking over the
time I can also zoom in zoom out if I
have multiple traces I can select ones
desct unct others in fact maybe
recognize it it's like plotly graphs so
in fact we have all the different charts
of plotly U so I'm going just to show
you this we have line charts catter B
charts well really whatever you want to
do with charts you can do it with
typi so this is like a PL chart that you
can uh really um it's really interactive
and then you've got the table that I
have chosen to display here so okay I
have created all this really in a simple
way but maybe I want to do something
when my slider changes like it is 24 43
how can I do something else like create
a callback from this and change for
example my
data I can do that in a multiple ways
I'm just going to show like two ways to
do it the first one will be to create a
callback function that I'm going to
create here so this is a cobal function
UNS slider it has the state as a
parameter the state is a type I concept
it just means that because we are
multi-user by Design we need different
states to differentiate between
different users so for example I have
state. value here but equal to 43 for
another like app it will be 24 26 so we
have like state do value will be the
runtime uh value of uh your value so
here what I want to do is when I'm going
to call this call back to have my state
of my data for me to change depending on
state of my value and when it's going to
be called well I want it to be called
when I'm changing my slider right so
unchange ons slider so when I'm going to
change my slider is going to call this
function that I've created with a state
in it and I'm going to change the state
of my data depending on the state of my
value so I'm doing
this and now I will have my chart uh and
when I'm going to change my slider we
will see that we have uh it like it's
interactive um because tyi knows where
data is in the different Ty elements
it's going to update everything that
needs to be updated like this so it's
one way to have this connection between
two variables um I can do another thing
to have the same behavior in fact I can
just arras pretty much all of my code
here and I can just put this
here so this is my app my complete app
is just this um what you see here is a
python expression I can put actually
python expression in my typ elements so
if you know like uh the F string uh
format in Python it's quite the same
thing you can put actual python
expression directly inside your type
visual
elements so when I'm doing this and
rning the
code I will have the same behavior
because when I change my value typ I
will know that value is in this um like
PA expression it's going to reload it so
here you don't need like any CBS just
the internal logic of typal will allow
you to create uh your application like
this so pretty simple uh but with this
you can create full multi-page
multi-user applications with lot of
different charts that are highly
interactive just like
this if we go back to uh the
same uh demo that I've shown you st VIs
ization maybe now you can understand
quickly how it's created I have my title
here I have layout which is just my
columns and then I have the different
visual elements so date date a button
that's going to do this function and
this kind of things so it's really
simple to create an application just
like this so I've talked about like the
charts also we have a lot of different
visual elements so text buttons inputs
well whatever you want normally you will
find it here uh it's called quite uh
there's a lot of
things so this is for the front end of
typei so how you can create different
charts different buttons that's going to
do things that is highly interactive but
like um Alex said we have also a back
end for typi that's going to be really
really useful when you create web
applications for data so I'm going to
show you that and um so it will be
here so I'm clicking here this is typeed
joke it's a vs code extension that we
have created for vs code and for tyi the
goal will be to have a lot of um like
help to create things so for example
this typei studio will allow me to
create the configuration for my back end
graphically so I'm going to be able to
edit the back end of my application just
like this by having um well just like a
graphical representation of my back end
so the backend is essentially just
pipelines you're going to be able to
configure it create your different data
notes to different task and then you're
going to be able to use your data inside
your application very easily for example
here my application that you see is just
an application for um for like I'm just
predicting on a data set to CSV I'm
going to clean it I'm going to have like
this clean data set I'm going to predict
on the day of prediction so it's going
to give me predictions and I'm doing
some evaluation
so what you see in blue are what we call
data so for example this one like I said
it's a CSV with a storage type CSV we
have a lot of different types of storage
types so P CSV Excel SQL wherever
you can just configure your data sources
just like this graphically uh and it's
going to be able to connect to your data
sources also if you have something
really specific to you you can just put
a generic data Note and you're going to
be able to create your own functions to
read and write your
data then I'm going to use this data
node I have a task so this task is just
a python function that I have in my
project we can see it here just a
function clean data but I'm going to
wrap inside typi with this concept of
task and like just like this I'm going
to create my pipelines I'm going to
create my data nodes and my like
everything like all the back end for my
application for my
data so in fact what you see um so like
I said it's an editor so I can create
new data notes I can create new task and
I can do everything just from here and
configure
it what you in fact doing is just
changing a to file to configure the back
end of tyi you could also do the same
thing but with just python so we have
also like this python API to do exactly
the same thing configure your data Note
it's a CSV it has a path configure all
the other detain notes the task and so
and so on just just like this so you
have like two ways to do it either
graphically or either with
python so when it's good okay you have
done your configuration you have
configured your backend and now you can
use it to create your application so
like Alo this is what I use for my
functions config this is just what I've
shown you and now I can go here this is
my code with the two pages I'm going to
show you I'm going to write this I'm
going to show you what it looks
like
okay so this is my
application so I have collected this
backend with this pipelines and I'm
going to be able to create scenarios so
scenarios is just a run of your pipeline
I'm going to be able to create different
runs of my pipelines I'm going to have
like a mystory of my pipelines going to
be able to compare them these kind of
things and this is what we call uh a
scenario tyi so for example I'm going to
say like to have a first
scenario I'm going to create
it and now there's a scenario uh here so
all this page was created with uh typy
I'm going to show you the code just um
after and so this is the representation
of a data node you can see the
properties of a data node in real time
you can see the history of what happened
to this data node we wrote it we have
changed it with which task and then you
have the data of this data if it's like
a command type like string in float time
pandas all of these kind of things we
can just read it and then you can change
it so for example I want to change my
day of prediction here I'm going to put
this one okay and I'm going to say okay
I want to change it so now I have
another value for my day of
prediction and this here is a scenario
viewer to see all the properties of my
scenario and I'm able to submit my
scenario like this so submit all the
pipelines all the task um and it's going
to populate my data nodes and these kind
of
things what you see here is the
different JS that have been placed so I
have submitted my scenario if it can
submit my test in parallel it will do it
and you will see the different jobs that
have been completed so everything work
fine there were no errors or I will see
it
here and the last thing that you see on
this page is uh the dag for my scenario
so for my P planes so all of this page
that you see which is quite complex as
you may think with this like scario
select where I can add scenarios where
I'm able like to also change like
different details this data not viewer
where I can edit my data uh change the
properties and so on um all of this this
has been done with just this lines of
codes so a scenario selector that is
bound to this scenario a data node fer
which is bound to the scenario day like
the day of
prediction uh a scenario um scenario
viewer for this scenario and then job
selector and S which is just really it's
um other typey visual elements that we
have cre just for the back end of typy
to be able to view it and submit
scenarios create ones delete them submit
them all of this really easily with typi
so all of this has Creed this
page the second page is just to view my
data so well maybe I can create another
one like create second
scenario create
okay and I'm going to submit it also
like that we have more data to show and
here it's the other page that I've
created for my application I have two uh
scenarios so same thing I can explore my
data just like this see properties this
story that has been done I have written
twice my
data uh the value of the day here it is
the evaluation like it's the end of my
pipeline so I know that the evaluation
for my predictions are like
2,598 which is just like
Mae and then I can also see my
predictions that I have just like this
so I can in fact also change it if I
want to I can change the values um I'm
also able to see them in the chart um
same thing as before change some
parameters add new traces and new um
elements to it if I want to and same
thing as before this page has been
created with just this line of code a
data selector
where I can select a data node and then
a data node viewer where I can like just
show my data Ty this kind of things um
with it but so pretty simple uh but like
that you can create your application
with just this L of code of course here
it's like all is done
graphically but um if you want to create
scenario with python you can also do it
so you can create scenario like this t.
create scenario based on the
configuration that you have done with
like this graphical um like U like
pipelines you can write data node just
like this scenario. dat node right
you're going to write your pipelines and
submit kind of the same thing TP submit
scenario so you can do whatever I've
shown you in the application also in
Python if you want to like there's ways
to do it which is kind of
flexible uh last thing I want to show
you is like is an application that was
built um with um well with tyi it's a
bit more complex than the other one here
it's like multi page multi user these
kind of things where you can see your
data so like here it's look like tables
but you have seen before charts it's
like normal Vis elements that we have in
tyi and the goal here is to be able to
create different scenarios for our
problem here the problem is like
prodution planning but it can be
whatever you want it's about like time
series predictions or anything you can
just create your application based
around it and the goal would be to be
able to change different your runs of
pip ples to see the different metrics
that has the different cost of your
solution uh what you have to do to be
able to uh act on on this data and you
can create different scenarios like I've
said with new parameters it's going to
give you new solutions that can compare
the kind of things so all of this can do
it pretty easily with tyi just using
normal visual elements of
tyi so when you are done with this well
it's quite yeah I think I'm shown you
everything that I wanted to to show you
so I will let you finish it thank you
very
much all
right yeah I know that's not it
but all right uh we have like 6 minutes
so maybe a few closing
remarks uh your first question might be
uh Y type ey compared to other Solutions
in terms of front end python deployment
so we've looked at the market and it's
divided in two groups so on one end
you've got things like plotly which is
very
complete uh you can do anything with it
but the only issue is the learning curve
is quite steep you need maybe a month to
learn how the product works on the other
and you've got well met BL Le and
youborn great but you can't deploy with
them uh the main thing would be stream
uh stream Le the main issue is that it's
not really built for production so as
soon as you press a button on a
streamlet app you stream L will rerun
your whole code to check what's changed
the issue with that is as soon as you
have a big app it's going to be really
slow and streaming also the issue is
that front end and back end on the same
thre on the same thread which means that
well if you have a model running in the
background your front end is completely
Frozen so we've separated the
threads another thing is type ey we you
can run typei in jupyter notebooks if
that's something for that you
need um something that will be releasing
really soon is typi cloud so basically
as soon as you have an app built with
typi you just put it in a zip file
upload it to our website and we'll host
it for you so really useful when you
want to do quick beta testing of your
products you just upload here and they
have access to it
online uh quick remarks on the road map
FL sure so for the road map what you
have seen with all this scenario
Explorer data viewer the kind of things
is going to be released like in the
upcoming weeks so it's not released yet
uh so it will be really now easy to well
just create your backend as I shown you
like graphically and then with some
those elements going to be able to do
anything with uh this back end so this
is something that is not uh like
released yet so now you just have to
create normal buttons to create your
scenarios and use Python to do it then
we have like typ cloud like um showed
you about which is going to be also
released like in the up weeks uh Dr P is
going to uh talk to you about it and
then in jary we also want to have U like
distributed uh Computing so it means
that you can call somewhere else and do
like the every work on a machine and
then you're going to get back the
results and manage it in your app so it
will be really uh better to to do this
way also I haven't shown like you this
but we have a previewer so when you do
like this mod syntax in fact you can
view it in real time and you can change
it um uh like in real time and have um
like because here what you have to do is
you have to run your code if you have
made a change like to it like if you had
another function or another elements but
in fact you can also have just a p
because it's Mar down and we're going to
translate it into like some kind of web
app but doesn't have it's on logic but
well and G buer it just means that drag
and drop where you're going to be able
to put your visual elements very easily
and then create your app so this is what
is to come for Ty the coming months
thank you very much for your attention
and don't hesitate to check out and
start our repo yeah thank
you